welcome back to my series exploring the
various ways that sounds change over
time and languages I'd like to wrap up
these videos with a look at rules and
laws when someone identifies a regular
sound change pattern in language or from
parent to daughter languages across
history that pattern is traditionally
called a sound law key laws are named
after their discoverers or popularizers
like Grimm's law laws may involve
Lanisha dissimulation or any of the
sound change types mentioned in previous
videos so Grimm's law defines a
systematic sound change in
proto-germanic the parent of every
Germanic language from Icelandic to
German to gothic to English part of
Grimm's law involves devoicing of voice
stops so the proto-indo-european root
Gwyn turned into Quinn woman the English
cognate is Queen
we can write that particular rule as
voiced stops become voiceless stops
Grimm's law and other sound laws are
built out of rules these rules are the
conventional way that historical
linguists state how sounds change in the
language the basic formula is simple
give the sounds that change the sounds
that they change into and the
environments where that change takes
place so in Portuguese the letter S is
pronounced between two vowels like in
the word Gazoo here's the rule notation
that tells us intervocalic s is
pronounced Z in that environment and
here is the rule that voiced stops in
proto-indo-european turned into
voiceless stops in germanic regardless
of environment the order in relationship
of rules is crucial for understanding
their significance in the development of
a language for instance you can use your
understanding of rules to establish a
relative chronology meaning that you can
determine which changes took place
earlier than others in a languages
history let's imagine a simple human
language will give it a cool name like X
X underwent two minor sound shifts in
one shift and became M before a labial
consonant this language has the labels P
and F in other words n assimilates - a
following labial in the second shift a
short unstressed a was deleted but only
if it occurred between two consonants in
other words unstressed it undergoes
syncope now X has a word mV
comparing data from closely related
languages just as we did in the
introduction to historical linguistics
we've been able to reconstruct the
protoform of that word as yeni fee now
that I've given you this info tell me
which sound change happened first
deleting it or changing end to M to help
you answer that question let's build
rules for the two sound changes first n
becomes M before a consonant with the
feature labial second unstressed it
becomes nothing when it's between two
consonants
if the proto word is Yenisei then
applying rule one first leaves us with
Oh
yennefer since n doesn't assimilate to a
following consonant it comes before a
vowel but then Rule two applies leaving
us with yen fee but language X has yen
feet not yen fee so scratch that try the
reverse order
Rule two turns yen fee into yen fee and
now rule one can apply leaving us with y
m fee which is exactly what we find so
it looks like Rule two took place before
Rule 1 which is our relative chronology
this fictitious but credible example
from language X raises awareness about
not only the timeline of rules but the
order of those rules when an earlier
rule creates an environment in which a
later rule can operate the two rules are
said to have a relationship described as
a feeding order the earlier rule feeds
into the second one so in language X
rule number one which deleted a allowed
rule number two which changed n to M to
apply that's an example of a feeding
direction when the rules are reversed
the earlier rule abandons and
environment which is filled by the later
rule the result is a counter feeding
order let's imagine that early in its
history our language X had a rule that
lead him before a consonant any
consonant whatsoever
the parent language had a word lumpy but
this first rule and becomes nothing
between a vowel and a consonant applied
to that proto word giving the output
left feet in language X a later rule the
one we're already familiar with changed
n to M before a labial consonant so rule
one deleted M s before consonant but
rule to put them right back in not in
the same words but it recreated the
environment when an earlier rule creates
an environment in which a later rule
cannot operate the two rules are in a
bleeding order the outcome the first
rule applies and the second one doesn't
go back to language X which has a rule
that deletes M after a vowel but before
a consonant it was this rule that
changed the proto word lam fee to
laughing young speakers of X are
applying a new rule these days they
insert a P in the consonant cluster MF
so instead of saying if they say but
they fail to apply rule number two -
laughing which lost its cluster MF
thanks to rule number one when the
bleeding rules are reversed the earlier
rule operates followed by the later rule
which would have prevented the earlier
rule from applying the result is a
counter bleeding order the outcome here
is different both rules apply return to
our rule in language X that deletes an
unstressed a in the middle of a word but
here's a new rule that moves stress to
the penultimate the second to last
syllable of a word that first rule
helped turn
yeni feet into yen fee but it also
caused the word of the Sun to change to
a sock
this new accent shift moves the stress
to the first syllable resulting in the
modern word off sucked instead of our
son had a FISA changed to a FISA it
would have prevented the rule that
deletes that unstressed in but since it
happens second the two rules apply in a
counter bleeding direction this series
has taken the time to share types of
sound changes with you as well as how to
state those sound changes using
phonological rules I appreciate your
interest in your attention throughout
this series and I thank you for taking
the time to learn with me